what up what up what's good bro nothing
much man nothing much right so my
question is you claim Jesus Is God right
that's what the problem says but doesn't
John 2017 say otherwise no how it it
doesn't say Jesus is not God yes I know
but it says Jesus has a God yes but
Jesus Is God no yeah so when you have
the trinity in light of the Trinity
Father Son and Holy Spirit share the
same Divine Essence so they're all God
Jeremiah 32: 27 says that God is the God
of all f F so when the son who is also
God takes on flesh that's when he
submits himself taking on flesh and the
father becomes his God in referring to
his flesh doesn't mean that he's not God
anymore or a different God it's just
that as he in that in that uh as he
takes on flesh he takes on that position
now where the father is his God
pertaining to his flesh but you still
didn't answer my question though I did
but in the verse he he says my God and
your God he still didn't answer it bro
just answered it to you the reason why
he can say that the father is his God is
because he's in the flesh so when he
took on flesh the father became his God
so God said my God and your God
according to you say that again so
according to you God said my God and
your God
yep yeah man that was my question bro oh
yeah that's what it is man he's still
Divine he still has the divine nature
he's still god with the father but
because he also has the human nature a
nature of Flesh that's when the father
becomes his God pertaining to his flesh
though so if you read on like same
chapter though have you read on to verse
20 have you like read beyond that have
you read the later verses no have you
ever heard of doubting Thomas no okay
well if we just continue in John chapter
20 we're gonna go down Jesus appears to
his disciples right um this is after his
resurrection he appears to his disciples
but Thomas is not there and so so the
disciples they tell Thomas hey man the
Lord is alive we saw him he came to us
Thomas says no I won't believe him I
won't believe him until I see him okay
so then Jesus shows up to Thomas he says
see here I am here are my hands look see
you see the holes it's me see my side
it's me right and then this is this is
Thomas's response to him Thomas then
answered him and said to Jesus my Lord
and my God so Thomas calls Jesus his
Lord Lord and his God just a few verses
later in same same chapter John chapter
20 after verse 17 we get we get going
Thomas calls Jesus his Lord and his God
now does Jesus say no don't call me that
no stop because I just told you I have
to go to my God and your God don't call
me that I'm not your God no he says this
is how Jesus responds he says Jesus said
to him have you believed because you
have seen me blessed are those who have
not seen and yet still believe so Jesus
affirms what what Thomas just said to
that he is Thomas's Lord and He is
Thomas's God but better off those
blessed are those who believe this even
without having to see Jesus so my
question would be why doesn't Jesus
correct Thomas here and say no I'm not
your God I just said I have to go to my
God and your God I'm not your God why
doesn't he correct him here and say stop
that why does he affirm what Thomas is
what Thomas says that he is his God why
does he affirm that now you got point I
don't know what what's in the air but
Nas I think you're good luck bro if
you're still listening you're good luck
because of you nas we're starting to get
some honest Muslims coming here oh yeah
I also want to get back about the man
burning the qurans but then but didn't
also other people memorize the Quran
cover to cover not really yes well which
the question would be which one did they
memorize which one did they memorize
because Muhammad told specific people to
memorize he sure did and you want to
know who one of those people were go on
IB Mass IB Mass was one of those people
who Muhammad said boom learn the Quran
from this guy there was four of them one
of them was I mas by the way the four
people that Muhammad said you should
learn the Quran from were not involved
in uthman's you know rewriting of the
manuscript where he came up with the
manuscript the perfect copy none
or and nobody else UB none of them were
involved in getting the Quran right why
don't you thinkman included them wa
included what why didn't utman include
none of the guys that Muhammad said you
should learn the Quran from when he was
burning the qurans and rewriting the
copy why didn't he include those guys to
make sure everything was right yeah but
didn't didn't Usman only rewrite the
house Quran no so
wrote all seven vergins yeah the Hadith
goes like this he asked HS to give him
the manuscript that she had so that he
can make copies of it so and even haa
was reluctant to give it to him so haa
ends up he ends up getting the Quran
from her and rewriting that copy into
perfect copies it says so he rewrote it
and then had all the other manuscripts
that people had he had them burned now
when he was rewriting it or had the
people re he had Zade Ben
rewrite Hasam and two others that I
don't remember exactly their names but
none of them were any of the four guys
that Muhammad said you should learn the
Quran from right who memorized it cover
to
coverb M these guys guys like that they
were not involved in this why did he
leave them out I don't know bro but
still surely if he changed anything
someone would have said something they
did he did I mass for example I Mass
disagreed with what Usman did and what
he was doing and he even told his
students to not turn into the not turn
in their qurans he told them to hide
their qurans from uan don't turn them in
that's what he said now why would
somebody you still didn't answer my
question though surely if he changed
something someone would have spoke up m
is speaking up he got beat up for it yes
but he didn't say you change in the
Quran but he's saying he's saying why
would I go after that Quran after what
they've come coming up with when I know
more than they do I've learned directly
from the prophet I know exactly what it
said when Zade was even was a little boy
wait what Hadith does it say whatever
you just talked about and nobody refuted
him yeah let me get that yes the prophet
Muhammad predicted the headphones yes I
used to it'll take me a second to have
to find it I used to have it say I don't
know what happened to all my stuff man
if anybody remembers that Hadith number
where I M tells them to hide their
qurans because he knows more than Zade
and stuff I didn't give that reference
what happened to all my stuff this
doesn't make any sense but do you know
the number of theith I don't I don't
remember it that's why I just I just
have the stuff saved in my phone but man
I lo I lost a lot of stuff and I don't
know when I don't know when the stuff
got deleted but used to have it all I
used to have all this type of stuff
saved I put it in an album called hyra
corons but so this is what I would this
is what I would say to just progress the
conversation that you know we we you do
clearly see differences even today ah
thank you John me out ter 3104 like it's
a bit of a long one but it's j op term
3104 so if you want to look look at that
one later on you can jat termity
3104 okay 3104 but yeah so we have uh we
have clear differences in the Quran that
we look at today clear differences you
know like in within the text like
between HS Quran and the war for example
or HS versus coloon or HS versus yes but
they all have the same meaning no no no
a lot of them change meaning okay give
me an example okay so in h Quran in
chapter 37:2 it says uh in the English
but you wondered while they mocked Allah
speaking to Muhammad when he recited the
Revelation to the disbelievers and they
mocked him verse 12 it says but you
wonder why they mock right the word is
aepa aepa yeah
and to means uh you wonder no a to means
I wonder no bro I speak Arabic to means
you you no a means you bro they both
mean the same thing no they don't come
on man is come on Brother come on man
we've been I've been through this so
many times I even I've even spoken to a
shake about this another Shake besides
myself I got a question for you why why
do you guys trust uh Paul if if Paul was
known as a murderer he was known as a
thief where does it say he was a thief
I'm pretty sure there's a verse that
says uh I steal from the churches to
where does it say he was a thief I don't
know somewhere in the Bible I don't know
the verse exactly no it doesn't there's
nowhere in the Bible where it says that
Paul's a thief okay what about him when
he used to persecute the P the churches
what happened when he was on his way to
persecute the church what happened I
know I'm asking you that's why I'm
asking you he converted he was on his
way to persecute the Christian and he
had a vision from Jesus and converted
and started spreading the gospel so he
claims to have had a a revelation from
God that completely changed his view to
now at first he was an enemy but now
he's an ambassador for Jesus he's a
warrior for Jesus but wouldn't that be
somebody that you you could trust
somebody as bad as him changing for the
good isn't he trustworthy no really yes
he could have just pretended he could be
just pret pretending that's true he
could be just pretending but if he's
pretending then his actions would show
that right however his actions show that
he actually genuinely had a conversion
because he stopped persecuting the
church not only did he stop persecuting
the church but he went to the apostles
to affirm his Revelation that he got so
and the apostles approved it but not
only that not only did he stopped
persecuting the church not only did the
Apostles approve of his testimony and
his
Revelation but God showed that he was
approved by him by doing Miracles
through Paul Paul did Miracles like like
Healing The Sick healing diseases
casting out demons okay but I could I
could say the same logic why would
Muhammad lie yeah why would Muhammad lie
what is he going to gain from that women
money power Paul yes but we all know
what he done with his money yeah yeah he
gave his he gave gave his wives uh homes
and he supplied his his army to go out
and pillage neighboring lands to make
them Muslim and threaten others to
become Muslim or else he'll take their
land so you have Paul who you have Paul
who in his conversion and by this
Revelation doesn't get women doesn't get
power he actually gets put in jail and
actually gets un alived for his
preaching and and uh what was the other
thing I said women power and money who
doesn't get money needs charity and help
from other churches and Ministries fact
working as a tier yes but can I can I
not say the same Muhammad's uncle died
he saw his own family die he went he
fought in war wait that has nothing to
do with let's let's actually break this
down okay so Muhammad's Revelation was
it approved by other Messengers and
disciples no but I'm pretty sure the
Christians that his his time we're
expecting a prophet they wasn't they
wasn't so you have Muhammad who was not
approved by other Apostles and
Messengers so no Witnesses no approval
Paul got witnesses and approval by the
apostles and Messengers so that's one
Paul one Muhammad zero let's go
next what did Paul gain by becoming a
Christian by converting to Christianity
and preaching ing the gospel prison
beating character defamation people
coming at his character accusing him of
things did I mention prison in prison a
lot torture and behead beheading death
right Paul gained no women no no women
no none of that
right Muhammad he was able to get power
took over Arabia by claiming to be a
prophet get more Believers give more
power then you're able to conquer people
so conquered Arabia was able to conquer
Arabia through his prophet he was able
to he was allowed to marry any believing
women that offered himself offered
themselves to him that's chapter 33: 50
of the Quran he gets whatever woman he
wants and money that he he got a large
percentage of the war booty that's
chapter eight of the Quran so money
women power Muhammad gets Paul doesn't
get Paul two Muhammad zero number three
Paul was proven that he was sent by God
and that God did Miracles through him
did Muhammad do any miracles
yes but the Quran says he did yeah Allah
Allah split the moon for it doesn't say
that he did it through Muhammad it says
in the Quran that the moon splitting is
a sign of the hour it doesn't say
Muhammad did it yes but many people
witnessed the Moon being split like who
like his companions where well we have
narration bro right okay so you have
Hadith that say Muhammad split the moon
no I never bro I never said Muhammad
split the moon he did I never when did I
say Muhammad split the Moon
I asked did he did he do Miracles yes
the moon split at his time did did Allah
split the moon through Muhammad split
the like you know how you know how Moses
split the sea how God split the sea
through Moses Moses putting the staff in
the water and boom did so did God use
Muhammad to split the moon like did
Allah tell Muhammad hey man raise your
hands to the sky and the moon will be
and I'll split the moon you know as a
sign like did he do that anything like
that honestly don't know the answer is
no the Quran says the Quran is clear bro
the Quran says that Muhammad is just a
Warner that's it he's just a Warner and
it actually goes even further this is
chapter 17 verse 59 it says we refrain
this is what Allah is speaking we
refrain from sending signs because they
disbelieved in the signs of old so Allah
says in the Quran we're not going to
give these people a sign because they
disbelieve the signs of the past through
the other prophets so we're not going to
give Muhammad a sign these people don't
deserve it they'll just disbelieve
anyway but you're just a Warner so the
Quran says Muhammad didn't do any
Miracles if you go on Hadith I'll be I
can tell you this if you go on Hadith
it'll tell you Muhammad did Miracles but
then you're at a you have a problem if
the Quran says no signs were given to
Muhammad but then you got Hadith that's
saying that Muhammad did signs and
miracles what do we go with there you
got the Hadith directly contradicting
the Quran you know what I'm saying does
that make sense bro no not really I got
to see the context of that verse
what doesn't make sense you see that
again what doesn't make sense no I just
said I don't know I got see the context
of the verse the context is they're
asking Muhammad for a sign in chapter
17:59 Allah said your mic's on mute the
verse says in 1759 we refrain from
sending signs what's difficult to
understand about that yes but that's
talking about when they were asking for
signs so if Allah doesn't send him give
him a sign and says that he's just a
Warner what does that tell you did he
perform Miracles or not yes but uh that
talking about when they were asking
asking for sand this is crazy y'all's
Quran will say something very clear and
then you guys will literally go against
it what is that is there like something
in y'all's drink or something and
Nothing Stops us from sending
signs except that the people of old
denied them and we sent the she camel to
tud as a clear sign but they did her
wrong and we sent not the signs except
to warn and to make them afraid so what
keeps Allah from sending signs to
Muhammad is that the people disbelieve
nowhere in the Quran is Muhammad a
miracle worker matter of fact all over
the Quran Muhammad is just a Warner
Allah didn't send any signs to him they
even go so far to say why hasn't
anything come down to you like like that
of Moses why has it nothing come down to
you like Moses did Moses received
Miracles we saw you know God appear to
Moses so Muhammad's not even a prophet
like Moses out goes Deuteronomy 18 yeah
I'm going to go do my research on that
so so far all three Muhammad zero so
when Muhammad has no witnesses to his
Revelation no Witnesses and no approval
by other Messengers or Apostles Muhammad
doesn't have any miracles to prove that
God is with him and Muhammad has a lot
of worldly things to gain money women
power he gets a lot of benefits in his
prophethood while Paul doesn't here's
another thing did you know that Muhammad
was Bewitched yeah yeah yeah Muhammad
was Bewitched Paul was never Bewitched
matter of fact Paul casted out demons
and healed people who were reaged yes
but Allah sent down on
him when he was Bewitched the fact that
you believe a prophet of God who's
supposed to be protected by God can be
Bewitched is is crazy yes he does he
does get protected by God he gets
protected how is he protected if he was
Bewitched yes Allah sends down on
him but how is he protected if he
actually gets Bewitched if he's
protected he wouldn't get Bewitched in
the first place yes he gets protected
after so he wasn't protected at first no
that's why Allah sent
down do you know what the Quran says
about people who get Bewitched like for
example bewitchment you would agree as
the power of the devil right BR I
literally just answered your question
did I not no you didn't yes Allah sent
down two suras protecting okay so Allah
helped him after he got Bewitched um let
me ask you this you agree that
bewitchment witchcraft are the powers of
the devil right let me show you what
what the what the Quran says about the
powers of Satan who can be subjected to
the powers of the devil this is chapter
16 I'm going start at verse verse 98 it
says so when you recite the Quran seek
Refuge with Allah from Shayan the
outcast verely watch this he has no
power over those who believe and put
their trust only in their lord so Satan
has no power his powers won't work on
those who trust in Allah and believe in
Allah watch this verse 100 his power is
only over those who obey and follow
follow him and those who join partners
with him with Allah those who are
polytheist so according to the Quran the
only people that's that can be overcome
by the powers of the devil where the
powers of the devil could work on them
are those who follow the devil those who
follow and those who ascribe Partners to
Allah those are the only type of people
that the de the powers of the devil can
work against Muhammad was Bewitched the
powers of the devil worked against
Muhammad at least for a time so that
means that Muhammad falls into the
category of those who followed Satan at
least for a time until Allah helped him
out hey what chapter was that chapter 16
chapter 16 verse verse 98 to 100
specifically 100 Satan's power is only
over those who obey and follow him
Muhammad was Bewitched the powers of the
of Satan worked against Muhammad so
therefore he was a devil follower he
followed the he followed Satan what's
that five Muhammad's 0 for five right
now against Paul no witnesses to his
Revelation no Miracles he gets worldly
gain from being a prophet money women
power he was Bewitched and while Paul
casted out those who were Bewitched had
power over those over witchcraft over
the powers of the devil and five this
would prove that Muhammad was a follower
of Satan because the devil's Powers
worked on him Muhammad doesn't compare
to Paul here's another one Paul met
Jesus Muhammad didn't meet Jesus no
Muhammad muhamad met Jesus yep they
prayed together oh Lord have mercy but
didn't Paul see Jesus's light and then
in the Bible it says the Satan disguises
a light no he didn't see Jesus as a
light he saw a light that blinded him
when he saw that he me no it's not
anyway so do you see how Muhammad has
nothing on Paul bro no
Miracles
Bewitched succumbed overtaken by the
powers of the devil no Witnesses no
Apostolic Witness and approval money sex
power influence all granted to Muhammad
through his prophethood so much to gain
wait what about Muhammad's prophecies
you still want to make a case for
Muhammad after all of this of course bro
why my my question now is right now for
you in light of what we just went over
why don't you trust Paul and why do you
trust Muhammad over Paul who clearly is
better than Muhammad because Muhammad
came with proof bro Muhammad came with
the Quran he came with prophecies and
Paul and Paul came with Paul came with
with quite a few books in the New
Testament okay with prophecies Miracles
okay but I thought only God knows the
knowledge of the Unseen so you just
prove that Jesus is God because Jesus
says in your Quran that he knows the
Unseen yeah yeah if yeah God could give
him the knowledge of the Unseen oh okay
Muhammad was illiterate Paul wasn't
illiterate Paul knew the scriptures
Muhammad didn't know the scriptures
never seen them because he was
illiterate I got a genuine question for
you how do you think Muhammad
prophesized the stuff he did he didn't
he didn't prophesize nothing can we keep
going yes he predicted the headphones
you said that with a smile Muhammad
predicted headphones yes you know what
he you know what he also said he also
said that sperm Will Survive within the
womb for 40 days and 40 nights before
before it becomes a child before it
becomes to before where you get that
from you just made that up you're right
I made it up
what is it say on the no I made it up
bro I made it up but if he did say that
like that would be like crazy wouldn't
it that'll show that he's false right do
you not just say Quran no I didn't say
Quran I said Muhammad said oh my bad my
bad but like if if if Muhammad said that
that would be crazy right I mean if it's
bro like the source is authentic is the
is I'm not ask I'm just asking if
Muhammad said that sperm Sean lasts in
the womb for 40 days and 40 nights that
would be crazy wouldn't it I don't know
would it bro I'm not a scientist bro and
and and clearly neither was Muhammad by
the way guys I was joking I didn't make
that up Muhammad really said that
multiple times if Muhammad is over here
lying come on you got show me Source at
least bro why what's the point because
maybe you're taken out of context
nothing that I show you bro nothing
everything that I show you you're just
gonna have an excuse for it you've
already shown that you can't be honest
so like you know it's it's just you know
there's nothing here for us man there's
nothing we can nothing I can do for you
nothing you can do for me you know to
you be yours may the Lord guide you man
but now that now now you know that
Muhammad can't even untie in the sandals
strap of Paul's shoes he's not worthy
now you know so when you ask whenever
you ask a Christian why Paul over
Muhammad you know now the question
should be for you that you're thinking
of as I let you go is why why Muhammad
over Paul why are you choosing someone
who's so obviously a false prophet
someone who was Bewitched someone who
didn't do any Miracles someone who got
money women and power from their
escavador by other Messengers or
Apostles why trust this person who goes
against the teachings of Jesus and the
apostles and the prophets who
contradicts them at every turn why go
with this person over Paul who's the
opposite that should be your question
all right take care of